you were about 17 when your dad got
sentenced to 50 years in jail she was
kind of like the John Gotti of his day
very high profile always under
investigation always a major Target of
law enforcement so I grew up with that
when my dad was ready to propose me he
said I got to ask you one question son
if you ever had to kill anybody could
you do it under the right conditions Dad
yeah I can do it he said that's the
right answer there was certain things I
did in that life that I was very
uncomfortable with quite honestly I kind
of stepped outside of myself hey I've
got an order this has got to be done
there was six of us the night I got made
five of them were murdered we were told
straight out you deal with drugs you die
you become an informant you pay with
your life your best friend walks you
into a room you don't walk out again he
would bring guys in there and actually
murder them chop up their bodies and and
disposing them as a matter of fact one
of the guys responsible for that is
getting out of prison fairly soon we
didn't obey the law we didn't care about
that you know we would do whatever we
had to do we bringing in 6 7 810 million
a week you know but they said to me look
look you're either going to cooperate
with us because he's implicated other
guys or we're going to indict you for
what this guy is saying I said take your
best shot I told him right then they had
me in lockdown for 29 months and 7 Days
in solitary you want to get out of here
you know just talk to watch leave me
[Music]
alone welcome back to the true Jordie
podcast everyone who knows me knows I
love anything Mafia related all the
gangster movies I'm addicted and I'm so
to say we have got one of the Real Deals
in studio today it's Michael Francis you
got it thank you for coming mate good to
be here all the way from America um
you're going to be doing a tour March
15th starts in London yes excited for
that and you're going to be around for a
while so there's loads of opportunities
for people to come and see you right
yeah three- We Tour Brian and and the
reason I came back I was here um not L
this summer but the summer before and it
was such a great tour people were
wonderful I didn't realize how into the
mob stuff they are here in the UK but uh
we had I think 15 dates and uh it was
great you know I met so many people and
uh just was excited to come back so I
think we're at three weeks uh probably
12 cities and uh very excited so can't
wait yeah well people people have to go
and check you out cuz I've been obsessed
with your YouTube channel for years now
and I want to give a little bit of
background for people who may not be
familiar with you because by the age of
35 Fortune Magazine listed Francis as
number 18 on its list of 50 most most
wealthy and Powerful Mafia bosses and
apparently generating up to $8 million a
week it was a life of crime for 28 20
years on the street arrested 18 times
eight years in prison um even name
checked in the good Fell's movie which
was where a lot of people would have
heard your name before without realizing
It Good Fellas is a movie that I am I've
just watched a million times what was it
like for you to be named in that movie
well you know I was kind of shocked I
had just gotten out of prison and so I
took my wife to see the movie and you
know she's not into all of the mob stuff
she lived through it so I had to almost
drag her to the movie you know so it was
funny Brian the way it opens up it's
pretty graphic you know stabbing him in
the car and all that so my wife turned
to me and she said is this what your
life was really all about and I said
come on honey it's a movie they make
things up don't don't worry about it no
sooner I say that then they have the bar
scene and there's Michael Franc so she
looks at me I come on let's go we left
right
cuz I'm saying this was a different
family but I knew Henry Hill very well I
knew Jimmy Burke very well so the writer
Nick pedi he put me in there he said
Michael you had name value you know we
wanted to put you in the film so it was
kind of a you know I didn't expect it
but um you know it's uh so many people
have mentioned that now because the film
was you know one of the best films ever
in that life really and your named in a
scene that is Iconic in that right
before the how might funny and all of
that bit so it's a bit that everyone
always wants to rewatch and uh you
mentioned Henry Hill obviously it is a
dramatized version of reality how far
away from reality was that movie in your
opinion well the movie was pretty
realistic as far as the characters the
way they were depicted the story was
pretty well on tap but you know and I
teased Henry about this Henry never
looked so good as he did in that
movie yeah that was a handsome man
playing him yes and they made him a lot
more important really than he was in
that life cuz he there he wasn't a maid
guy obviously cuz his dad was a was an
Italian but you know Henry had some
issues I mean he had a drug issue had an
alcohol issue so he wasn't that
prominent in the life but uh you know
hey it was a great movie they did a good
job and you know I actually seen a video
of Henry as an older man going back
around the old neighborhood and even
still being
very frightened you know in his older
age even well let me tell you what
happened I'm in uh terminal Island
prison and I'm doing my time and I was
in there for a couple of years and I I
walk out into the yard and we just got
out of the chow hall and I see a guy and
I kind of recognized him I didn't
realize it was Henry because he had he
had really aged right so I go back to my
cell and the lieutenant calls me into
the office and he says to me Michael uh
did you notice somebody in the yard I
said no what are you talking about you
he come on Michael it was Henry and
Henry at that time was on separation
from all of us because you know had
cooperated and all that and he looked at
me and he said you know Henry just pced
up he put himself in Pro protective
custody because he saw you and you know
he's in trouble I said he's got nothing
to worry about with me so we're going to
have to ship you out they were going to
ship me out I said hey I've been here
for a couple of years is close to my
ship him out right so finally they did
but uh that was kind of the last
encounter I had with him wow yeah and in
terms of like you know the entertainment
side of things the depictions that we've
seen so many times is there a a movie or
a TV show maybe Sopranos or a movie that
you look at and you go you know that's
the closest thing they got to the real
life yeah well a couple you know the uh
this was the 1996 HBO movie movie called
Gotti and it was armanda Sante and
Anthony Quinn brilliantly done I mean
armanda Sant played Gotti so well
Anthony Quinn there was a scene in there
that gave me the chills that Anthony
Quinn did it so well and it was pretty
accurate because they did it right
according to the surveillance tapes and
the and that they had on him so that's
that's my number one as far as
authenticity if you go to uh Donnie
Brasco I thought that was uh Al Pacino's
best role I knew Angel uh Lefty really
well he played him so well uh you know
then listen Casino was great you know
was a good movie uh obviously Good
Fellas um there's there's a couple of
good ones out there and when you get
scorsi and that crew together they can't
make a bad movie I mean it terrific can
you remember your first sort of
realization of what this was when you
were a child like being understanding of
Mafia well you know Brian my dad uh was
such a high-profile figure back in the
late 50s and 60s he was kind of like the
John Gotti of his day very high-profile
always under investigation always a
major Target of law enforcement so I
grew up with that my dad was constantly
being arrested charged with you know
criminal activity he went to trial three
times we had agents around us all the
time surveilling us so even though my
dad didn't discuss it in the house I
mean he had so much media and everything
I kind of knew what was going on even at
a young age but you know the real eye
openening thing that happened with me
Joe Columbo who was the boss of the
Columbo family my dad had gone to prison
and we were at a uh an Italian-American
civil rights League rally at Columbus
Circle in New York and uh you know he
had put this whole league together
because he said Italians were being you
know harassed by the FBI and it was that
day uh I was up on a stage with him he
had called me over to hand me some
brochures that he wanted me to hand out
about the league and I walked 12 steps
away from him and that's when he got
shot it was an attempted assassination
he got shot he eventually died from the
wounds he was in a coma from that point
but that that made me realize hey this
is the real thing it was the first time
I had witnessed something like that so
can you give us an idea of what the
Columbo family was like and and and what
kind of characters were in there and
what the status of that family was in
New York well you know I always say the
the golden years of the mob in America
of Coen or in America really from the uh
the late 40s right through to the mid
80s so I was in that era because
obviously my dad throughout the 60s I uh
I really got involved in the Life in
1970 when my dad went to prison and I
became a maid member in 1975 so I was in
the midst of what I call the golden
years and the Columbo there's five
families in New York and the Columbo
family is one of the smaller ones we
were we had about5 made guys we had a
lot of Associates but guys that actually
took the oath and um I mean look it was
a real deal I mean you know that's
that's it was during a time in New York
we had a lot of power and a lot of
control we controlled all the unions we
had a lot of political power and we had
a lot of power on the street you know so
I was in the midst of all of that and
that was a time when you know Joe
Columbo Kine perso who was my boss uh
Fat Tony solo the boss of the geneves I
mean Paul castalano John Gotti that was
the era so I mean I you know I knew all
of those guys and I think from what I
read up you were about 17 when your dad
got sentenced to 50 years in jail now
even if we remove the mafia element of
it that's a hell of a blow to a young
man to probably lose what was probably
his Hero at that age you just describe
what that was like for you it was tough
because my dad was he was 50 years old
when he went in and he got a 50-year
sentence to figure hey you're going to
die in prison you know uh and it was a
blow because my dad was my idol he was
my hero growing up and to have that loss
like that was was very very tough but
you know and I say this Brian my dad
obviously did a lot of bad things in
that life so did I you know during my
time but that particular crime that my
dad did all that time for he did 40
years on the 5050 uh he was innocent of
he was 100% framed I investigated that
case thoroughly we spoke to every
witness that testified against him they
all recanted their testimony we gave him
lied detective test proved they lied at
the trial and the FBI was complicit in
that with him so as a result that I had
a real hatred for government because hey
they framed my father took him away
destroyed my family the whole bit so it
was really a blow and you know prior to
that my dad didn't want me involved in
the life he wanted me to go to school be
a professional be a doctor and it wasn't
until that he went to prison that my
life changed and I got out on the street
basically to help him out cu without
that he's going to die in jail so I mean
it was a life-changing experience for me
it was it was Bank Robbin that they
framed him for is that right he was
supposedly masterminded a nationwide
string of bank robber he gave the order
to the to the bank robbers and uh you
know it's just a bad case we can never
get it overturned could never get the
conviction overturned did you ever want
him to snitch
like just to get him back did you have a
wish that he would when you were young I
I didn't understand that concept back
then you know but no but you know what
really what got me with him is my dad
was out on parole five
times and he kept getting violated for
association with other criminals you're
not allowed to do that when you're on
Federal peole and like his third time I
started to get upset with him I said dad
our family's falling apart you got to
get away from these guys you know you
you can't make make it here in New York
you're too high-profile a figure but you
know that was his life and uh you know
as a result he he stayed in it and just
kept going back to jail I don't know if
this is the same way for you but
obviously in my life sometimes I feel
like I've become my dad's dad like how
did your you know relationship with him
evolve over the course of that time as
he's imprison aging and you're Now sort
of rising the power outside of jail well
yeah it was kind of maybe a little
uncomfortable because you know I become
a soldier in 1975 1980 I was elevated to
position of
Captain and he was a captain when he got
out so we were both equal ranks at that
point wow but he really couldn't do
anything because of his parole situation
and I was doing everything you know so
it made me a little bit uncomfortable
because I always looked up to my dad as
being you know up there and then we're
kind of equal in that life even though I
gave him all the respect because you
know he he deserved that you know he was
kind of a you know a stalworth in that
life but it changed a bit because you
know and this is hard to say Brian but
you know I always looked up to my dad as
being this invincible guy and when he
came home it wasn't the same you know I
expected him like to come out and we're
going to take over the family and all of
that but it it didn't happen that way so
I was a little disappointed I think I
put a little too much pressure on him in
that regard you know um you know there
was a point in time you know I I can
share this when our boss Kine persal he
broke my father meaning he took my
father's captaincy away so my father's a
soldier and I'm a captain you know I'm
higher in rank I was very upset about
that I said Dad how can they do that to
you you know you got 50 years you never
opened your mouth you never said
anything and it was very disappointing
to me to the fact where I wanted to go
to war with people I was that mad you
know but he said no you know abide your
time and they used it as an excuse they
said you know you're always getting
violated so we're going to take you out
of everything so that you know you don't
have to be part of you just stay there
and let your son do everything but I
took it as a real slap in the face he
was smarter he said just let it go don't
worry about it that's how this life is
but it was very disappointing to me you
were standing on his shoulders
essentially to become the person you
became so now to see the man who started
it all be disrespected it must have yeah
like invoked that emotional reaction in
you and from what I understand part of
the reason it could be wrong but part of
the reason they wanted to make you
earlier than what would normally happen
is kind of as a node of respect to your
old man who who did the right thing in
their eyes and didn't rat on his friends
and all of that so yeah to then take his
captaincy away yeah it's a backhanded
thing right it it was and yeah they gave
him the courtesy CU you know when I got
made there was a uh an expression that
the books were closed from the 50s right
into the mid-70s meaning they weren't
bringing any new guys into the family
the only way you could do that and this
was all five families if somebody died
you were able to replace them wow so now
in
1975 when I got made there was a ton of
guys that were waiting 20 years to
become made and I got moved up to the
front as a courtesy for my dad I mean I
still had to prove myself you know two
and a half years but they moved me up in
front of a lot of guys so some guys were
resentful of that but my dad deserved
that respect cuz he needed me on the
street I had a to get him out of prison
he needed me there so he asked for that
and they did it uh and then yeah you
know later on to kind of be
disrespectful in that regard because
they could have said to him look you're
still a captain just stay away from
everything don't get violated again but
to take that away from him was was tough
I can only assume from their point of
view that like if we do him this favor
he's more likely to keep his mouth shut
and like we're all in this together
still of thing I mean look my father
could have buried a lot of guys no
question about it and he wouldn't you'd
have to kill him for first he wouldn't
have even thought of that he was he was
the most standup guy in that life that
you ever want to meet no doubt I can say
how much pride that gives you when you
talk about him in a lot of your
interviews and I you know I've seen the
the sit down with Samy uh gravano and
he's challenging you and and I feel like
a lot of where your self-worth comes
from is like this guy Built Me And He
you can't question that you know what I
mean it's admirable that he was like
that you know what I mean despite
obviously being a criminal there was a
certain code there that in the today's
criminals that we've got all over London
pulling knives on these innocent little
kids out here they don't have that do
you ever look at modern criminals with a
sense of like disgust you know I do
because I I just can't understand the
mentality you know look I never glorify
my former life you know because I always
say it's a bad life because families get
destroyed as a result of membership in
that life my family was destroyed you
know you know and I I tried to preserve
my family when I say my family I mean
mother father brother sister destroyed
but my family I preserved them from that
but you know when I look at these guys
today I mean I I I just don't understand
you know there's no we had a certain
honor and a certain respect about us we
took care of our communities our
neighborhoods there was no crime in our
neighborhood none whatsoever you know we
took care of the people that's why even
you know a lot of guys said that you
know why was John Gotti so loved he was
loved in his neighborhood like my father
was like I were because we took care of
people we didn't hurt people where we
were you don't see that today you know I
don't know how of these young kids now
oh yeah in the United States I can't
believe what's going on there I mean
they're just wild animals I mean it's
it's crazy really yeah I mean crime is
is never great but like again not
glorifying what your life was but
equally it certainly deserved more
respect than today's you know young
criminals who are out here just stabbing
people just to prove they can do it yeah
I mean that and that that's happening a
lot right now in the UK and London
especially um and in terms of being M
can you describe that process of what it
really means and and what you do and who
you're with and that sort of thing well
when I was proposed my dad proposed me
for membership you know in that life you
can't go up to somebody say hey I'd like
to join somebody has to propose you
vouch for you say you had what it takes
in my case was my dad so um after Joe
Columbo was shot and seriously wounded a
new boss took over his name was Tom
Della and I sat with Tom after my dad
sent word from prison and he said to me
Mike um I got a message from your father
you want to become a member of our life
yes from now on 24 hours a day seven
days a week you're on called to serve
this family the Columbo family that
means if your mother is sick and dying
you're at her bedside we call you to
service you leave your mother you come
and serve us we're number one in your
life before anything and everything when
and if we feel you deserve this honor
this privilege to become a member will
let you know from that point on you're
in a recruit period you got to do
anything and everything you're told to
do to prove yourself worthy and you know
Brian I I hate to be offensive to
anybody but I got to be honest you know
when my dad was ready to propose me he
said I got to ask you one question son I
said what's that he said if you ever had
to kill anybody could you do it and you
know kind of a question you don't expect
but I thought about it for a minute and
I said under the right conditions Dad
yeah can do it he said that's the right
answer and that's all he needed to hear
from me because he knew me you know
obviously and um you know look the life
is violent at times there's no way to
get away from it you know if you're part
of the life you're part of the violence
we keep it within ourselves but that's
the way it is and uh and then you had to
obey orders you know there's a lot of
discipline in that life you had a
meeting at 8:00 you weren't there at
7:30 you were late you can never be late
no excuse I don't care if there's
accidents if there's an earthquake you
got to be on time period you know go
there the night before if you have to
but uh you know Drive the boss to a
meeting sit in the car 3 4 5 hours you
know you leave to go to the bathroom or
or get a newspaper he comes out you're
not there you're in trouble I did that
once I know a lot of stuff like that you
know you're on call to do whatever
you're told to do and you got to prove
yourself worthy and if and when you do
then you get the privilege uh of being
made you know without admitting too much
uh you were asked to do a lot of things
and and there was there was guys um from
what I understand in your story the guys
you were made with were murdered as well
all five of them yeah yeah wow were six
of us the night I got made five of them
were murdered that shocked me because in
all the movies there's this idea of if
you're a ma guy you can't be touched
that is the theory behind it but
obviously obviously doesn't always work
that way no Brian you have certain rules
and if you break the rules you know you
could pay with your life you're told
straight out
don't ever violate another man's you
know wife daughter sister mother that's
death at that time and I know I get a
lot of controversy about this you know
we were not allowed to deal with drugs
we were told straight out you deal with
drugs you die and I knew people that
made that mistake you know you become an
informant you pay with your life you
know so there's a lot of things like
that you know so you know how you look
at it and I don't I'm not justifying but
hey we all took the same oath we all
understand this is what we're not
supposed to do and if we do it we're
going to pay the consequences so you
almost feel Justified well he broke the
rules he knew better you know but again
you keep it within you know a lot of
people think that when you take the oath
of omera that it's an oath to lie steal
cheat kill it's not the O of Omer means
silence you're never even supposed to
admit that the life exists that's what
you take obviously as a part of that
life you know we didn't we didn't obey
the law we didn't care about that you
know we would do whatever we had to do
but uh and and you know I have to say
this you know for your audience murder
was not a first action it was always a
last resort you know and in our life was
very serious only the boss can okay you
know if something had to go down the
boss would would give the final word on
that and then whatever happened happened
from that point but I think a lot of
people get the impression especially
from movies we just went around killing
people every day like some of these
young kids today not the truth at least
not through my experience one thing that
really hit me about your dad's story
just before we move on from him was that
your own brother testified against him
and knowing the way you are about your
dad I could only imagine that must have
been quite
heartbreaking it it was it was shocking
quite honestly even though my brother
had a severe drug problem uh but we
never expected it to go to that level um
yeah and I was I was at the trial when
my brother was was testifying it was
like is this really happening you know
uh but you know Brian honestly too and
my brother was in the WT Protection
Program so like 10 years I didn't see
him after that I had a 70th birthday two
years ago and my wife invited him and
cuz he was out of the program and I was
like stunned when I seen him you know he
showed up I didn't know it was a
surprise for me but you know I got to be
honest Brian my brother sat down with me
and he he said I don't know if you
understand the torture that we went
through as a family and you know look I
had a sister died of an overdose of
drugs my younger sister 41 years old she
was never mentally stable she passed
away at 41 my mother dies 33 years
without her husband and her life at the
end was a mess and then my brothers did
drugs testify it's destructive to the
family so he started telling me some of
the emotion that he felt as a kid
growing up and some of the resentment he
had from my dad
and I I almost understood cuz it kind of
opened my eyes for some
reason I kind of survived all of that
where my brothers and sisters didn't but
hearing it from his perspective I said
you know I never thought of things this
way you know and the kid went through a
lot he really did and uh it's
heartbreaking it really is and now a
word from our sponsors this podcast is
brought to you by flexispot flexispot
make the next generation of death so
that you can have the best setup but
also the most comfortable now the one
I've got is the A7 Pro and the reason
for this is that standing up is much
better for you than sitting down all day
hunched over while you're working and
how does it work well it's very easy on
the little keypad you can program up to
four preet Heights at the touch of a
button and this one goes from 63.5 CM
all the way up to
128.57 so even if you're a tall block
like me you can still feel very
comfortable while you're working oh and
the keypad actually comes with a
built-in USB Speed Charge out which is
very handy and for the people out there
who tend to have a lot of work on their
desks or even the gamers who want to
have a full gaming setup this is perfect
because it supports a whopping 160 kg of
weight this is built better than the
Titanic and actually if Jack and Rose
had had this desk in the water with them
they'd both be alive to tell the tale
and I've gone for a big Works Space here
so I've got 160x 80 cm bamboo top
everything is fully customizable in
terms of size and material and also the
legs come in different colors as well
and one of the best bits about it is it
comes with a cable management slot which
keeps everything organized and tidy
under the desk so if you want the best
desk setup possible then you've got to
check out flexi spot just click my link
in the description below they've also
got chairs and storage to complete your
setup to make it perfect just for you so
thanks to flexi spot but for now enjoy
the video yeah you're quite a stoic
person who probably I mean there's a
reason you're still here to tell the
tale right like you are made of tough
stuff uh and I think I watched one
interview where you mentioned uh you
mentioned your mother there about how
you thought that they might have based
Tony Soprano's mother on the wiretaps of
something that they had in your house on
your mother which kind of made me laugh
cuz Tony Soprano's mother was the
greatest character in that show so I
thought what must your mother have been
like she must have been such a character
um my mother was extremely in she was
she was my father's match no doubt about
it very independent um you know she she
was rough to get along with MH rough to
get along with and uh so there was
always a lot of turbulence in the house
Mom and Daddy it was it was very very
tough but somehow I survived it I don't
know and the rest of them didn't and it
really affected them and I and I kind of
understood you know and now my brother
and I are close again and I get knocked
from oh your brother was a rat you're
this and that you know you and I said
hey don't it's my family you know don't
tell me what to do but I really
understand in a way where he's I don't
agree with it don't get me wrong you
know I don't agree with what he did but
I understand yeah forgiveness is a is a
thing that I I mean getting older myself
now I'm finding it's coming easier and
easier whereas when I was younger I'd
hold a grudge yes um and I think it's
good for you in your old day years now
to be able to like let things go A bit
you know I found that holding a grudge
and uh you know being resentful is is a
burden to yourself MH you know if you
can let it go and uh and accept things
that happened in the past like you know
a lot of guys on my on my social media
platform oh you know you're friends with
Sammy Grano and Samy and I we but buted
heads I think you saw and that was real
by the way it was real oh yeah but we
kind of patched it up afterwards I said
look Sammy whatever you did you know
whatever I did we did that was our past
and there's no sense in taking that you
know at at this point in time in our
lives and I kind of look at at that with
everybody you know I mean why not why
was Sami so sort of hostile towards you
you know sami's a different character
you know um and I got to like him a lot
and I like his family his you know I
interviewed his uh his daughter Karen
was one of the best interviews ever she
was so honest so I related to her
feelings with her dad me with my and his
son uh uh Gerard you know nice people so
and I look at that you know you raised
great kids you know as far as I'm
concerned but you know he was hostile in
in the beginning because he's the one
that brought it out oh jumped ahead of
everybody when you got made and guys
were resentful I said hey what do you
want from me I didn't make that decision
they made that decision you know don't
worry about it but you know we buted
heads but then I don't know what was on
his mind at that point I felt like
watching that interview and I I'll give
you my opinion see what you make of
it he
really the identity of him being like
that bad the bad man you know the killer
you know to then have to be hold a rat
by so many people because of the way it
ended for him and and listening to the
story about him and how people were
ratting on him so it was kind of r or be
ratted on like really but I feel like
that really bothers him and the fact
that you also gave up some information
MH but weren't giving up people right
made him feel like oh but you're not
better than me though and there was this
in um what's that word uh he he felt a
bit like oh I feel
like uh what's the word maybe inferior
in some way shape or form and he he had
that like complex about well he doesn't
make you any better cuz we both gave up
information so therefore we're both as
bad as each other and I felt like he was
constantly trying to push you into that
yeah I I agree with that I think that
was part of it you know because look
even though you did something like that
you don't want to be known to be a bad
guy and I understand that I totally do
so I and and I got it afterwards you
know um and I think you know a lot of
the guys that were in that position that
you know cooperated and went into the
the program and and testified and things
like that I think they don't feel good
about it none of them do you know and
whatever the circumstance whatever the
reason was that pushed him into that you
know I don't want to pass judgment on
that but I think that was part of it but
after we got past that you know and I
said Sammy I'm not judging you you're
not judging me whatever it it is what it
is and then we we put it to rest it's F
it's fascinating that these like a guy
who's done the things he's done can now
just be a YouTuber yeah like that's so
bizarre to me
all of us you know I mean whoever
thought we'd be on YouTube I mean when I
sit and think about it at times I said
this it's crazy it really is okay so the
thing that you are really well known for
is being a great earner and if there's
one thing I've noticed from all of this
uh you know mafia movies it's if you're
a good earner people are going to like
you uh but you were around killer so
like how did you you know they're
probably jealous of you being in the
good books with the boss giving him all
that money how did you navigate that
whole situation and how did you amass so
much money
well you know it's true because I was
one of the younger guys too and you have
resentment from you know just like
everyday life you know the older guys
they kind of have resentment for the
younger guys you have to navigate that
course in in that life because it could
be you know things are more intense in
that life you know and and maybe you
lose a position in in real life in that
life you could lose your life you know
you got to be careful who you rub the
wrong way um do you have to stay humble
a lot like you do cuz if you're giving
it Cockiness exactly these guys aren't
going to like you at all exactly and you
have to give difference to the older
guys just because they've been there
longer and that's it you know and then
spread the wealth you know listen in
that life Money Talks you know and uh
you you kind of separate yourself in
that life you have the
racketeers which are the guys that
bringing the money and then you have the
gangsters that do a lot of the work you
know and I always say this a gangster
normally can't be a racketeer because
they don't know how to use the life to
earn you know but a racketeer has to be
a gangster and a racketeer because if
you're called upon to do something you
got to do it and um I kind of separated
myself as a guy that knew how to earn I
mean I knew how to use that life to
benefit me in business and went on to
make a lot of money and when you do that
you rise in the ranks you know my boss
was very appreciative of that I made him
a lot of money and uh but the other
thing is people want to be around you
when you're an earner so if you navigate
that properly and let people earn the
people that are supposed to be earning
with you then you do okay you know but
you also have to know listen there's
there's always a point where even the
older guys they can't push you because
you're equal you're all equal you know
you're told when you become a ma guy
we're all equal everybody's the same so
you only give difference to a certain
point but at some point hey you know
enough and you got to put people in
their place and that happened to me
quite a bit but um you know fortunately
I was table I I can say this Brian I
didn't make a lot of enemies if I had
enemies it was just resentment because
of who I was and I was younger but I
didn't make enemies I didn't go out
there to make enemies you know I always
I always live by this the best way to uh
defeat your enemies is to make them your
friends and I I have that same thing now
you know a lot of guys take knocks at me
on YouTube and I never respond to them
and the guys that were knocking me who I
never even met I didn't even know who
they were you know but you that's how
people start on their platform now
they're all coming to me and we're
friends because I said to them if you'd
ask me maybe to come on your show or do
this I would have came you didn't have
to start knocking me you know and all of
that we can help each other we're not
competing Here YouTube yeah YouTube is a
big platform there's room for everybody
you know but I understand I understand I
don't hold it against anybody but you
know now we're all friends it's a it's a
better way to be yeah you had you kind
of had to be a politician back then as
well like to know how to play everyone
and I I guess that old saying is keep
your friends close keep your enemies
closer absolutely and another saying
that I've come up with lately uh which
is not everyone um something along the
lines of some people who are your
friends are only your friends cuz they
haven't got the balls to be your enemy
absolutely and and you know the older I
get the more I realize that and and from
from what I researched one of your
biggest money makers was the gasoline
business so can you kind of break down
how you manag to use uh your brains to
to think of getting all lot money out
with it well you know it was a guy that
came to me that was in the gas business
had a small operation and he had the
germ of an idea of taking defrauding the
government out of tax on every gallon of
gasoline and he came to me with this
idea and we were able to expand it I was
able to help him and expand it into a
very major operation when I say major we
had uh we ran it for about 8 years and I
had over 300 uh about 350 guest stations
325 350 I either owned or operated we
leased so we were supplying all of them
and then I had 18 companies that were
licensed to collect the tax on every
gallon of gasoline and then we devised a
way to collect it and not pay it I mean
the scheme was simple the operation was
complex because we had to hold the
government off from coming down on us
you know and I would get about a year
out of every license before the
government would come down on us and
then we would just destroy that and move
on to the next company so we just kept
doing it it was a daisy chain and they
couldn't figure it out so to give you an
idea of the numbers at the height of my
operation we were selling a half a
billion gallons of gas a month taking
down 20 30 40 cents a gallon whatever
the mark whatever deal we made at the
time so we were bringing in six s810
million a week you know on average so it
was it was I I would say this and I
think it's hard to dispute that was
probably the biggest money-making deal
since the days of prohibition other than
drugs but we weren't big in the drug
business the mafia in Italy big drug
dealers we weren't big in the United
States so this was probably the biggest
operation since prohibition yeah
apparently you were second only Al
Capone in terms of money generated well
that's what the media said I don't I
don't want to say yes to that but who
knows it's a pretty cool uh title to
have and and the drug thing is quite
interesting because in all the movies it
they they reiterate that as well like
you know you stay away from drugs
because drugs are the kind of sentences
that will make people break and have you
ever tried
drugs I've never even smoked a joint my
life I'm going to be really honest I
took one uh I was like 20 years old I
was with some girl and she gave me a
half of a qualude oh okay a half and I
said after that I'm never Wolf of Wall
Street I'm never again that was the end
of that but uh I hate anything to do
with drugs Brian because I saw how
destructive was in my own family so
never smoked a joint never I mean a
prescription if I'm giving one
fortunately I'm pretty healthy so I
don't have to but but no won't ever
touch it cuz you're friends with Mike
Tyson and he has his own marijuana PL
I'm thinking maybe uh Big Mike will give
you a taste well he tried I did his hot
boxing thing and he's smoking he says I
said hey I'm going to be the first guy
that refuses to join so don't give me
any I love it yeah but you got wh wine
uh companies right I'm in a wine
business yeah Francis wine I'm a I'm a
big F a wine so hopefully I'll get some
of that well you're going to give me
your address well well actually I got
some bottles coming over here so I'll
make sure you get one sure amazing and
and going back to this um you know this
right in the middle of your life that
you were in in the story you were
talking about murder's not being as
common as what people think right um in
terms of the brutality you know and how
violent it could be um one guy who's
sort of been you know waxing about how
you know in-depth and how violent his
murd with the ican and you've kind of
talked a little bit about him um are you
now sort of settled on it was mainly
with him or do you think he was
the real deal it it was BS with respect
to in the movie they had him like a very
prominent figure with Roy Deo and all of
that that wasn't true absolutely not
true I mean I knew Roy fairly well um so
they they really you know overplay in in
the movie but look I have to tell you
this you know I'll men Roy Deo and I
don't like talking about people but he's
gone now he was a different character I
mean Ro Roy was a a serial killer I mean
there's no other way to describe it you
know and I I like to tell people this
the mafia did not make Roy who he was he
would have been the same way without our
life I mean actually we you know we we
made it easier for him because he had
you know men a group of people around
him but you know Brian I don't know
anybody of that caliber that was that
brutal that lasted that life you don't
last because people say who wants to
mess with this guy you know let's get
rid of him everybody I knew that was
murder first never lasted in that life
can you give an example of how brutal he
was to people who don't understand the
the levels oh gosh well he had a you
know I mean they and again the media
always overplays this the media said my
dad was responsible for 40 murders but
never named one you know so they who
knows but Roy they said over 200 murders
in that life and this was highly
publicized but he did have a a method
called The Gemini method he had a club
in uh in in the city and he would bring
guys in there and actually murder them
chop up their bodies and and dispose of
them and that was a fact I mean that
happened as a matter of fact one of the
guys responsible for that is getting out
of prison fairly soon you know that it
was part of Roy hopefully he's he's
changed his life and calm down a bit but
uh it was pretty he was a brutal guy no
question about it of all the guys you
met in in your own family and your like
close um work in relationships maybe was
there one that stuck out to you as the
one of the scariest
guys you know the only guy that I ever
had to be concerned about and that was
scary to me was my boss Kine perso he
was a real he was a real deal an oldtime
tough guy no question about it he was a
street Warrior and I had to watch myself
with him because he had the power of
life and death over me he was a guy did
you say he was nicknamed a snake or
something call they called him the snake
yeah that was the reputation that he had
I got along great with that's a worri
and nickname in that line I mean I got
along great with him you know we like
until until I walked away then he was
very upset with me but he was already
doing a 100 years in prison at that
point but um you know people say well
you afraid of Roy Deo I had no reason to
be afraid of Roy Deo you know look I
have to say this Brian we were all
capable of putting a gun in our hands
and doing what we had to do so I didn't
have to worry about anybody yeah except
my boss if I would to step out of line
so I didn't worry about anybody else in
that regard but I had you know I was
very mindful of doing the right thing so
that I didn't put myself in trouble and
guys in the mafia are always portrayed
as having multiple women you know the
gumar thing and that like on The
Sopranos the the waight I'll be greeting
him as if he hasn't seen him in a week
when he seen him last night yeah is is
that the way it was with multiple women
or it is part of the life I'm not going
to I'm not going to you know disavow
that but it's not as as out there as
people make you know as you see in the
movies and the media it wasn't that guys
didn't respect their wives I mean they
did but you know it's a lifestyle where
you're out six nights I was in a club
six nights a week so you know who's in
there and then of course you know women
are attracted to us I have to say you
know whether it's the money the power
the bad boy image or who knows you know
so you have women around all the time so
if you put yourself in the Lions then so
to speak you know it's part of that life
I heard you telling a story about a gay
guy in the mafia and I wondered if that
was something that uh was you know
happened every now and then or if it
would be exposed or death really oh yeah
no absolutely frowned upon you you'd be
in a lot of trouble wow you'd get killed
over that oh yeah wow without a doubt
yeah you can't I mean you better not
expose that wow yeah instant I mean cuz
we're in such a different world right
now right and I think even for people
who watched all these movies even just
to hear that is quite shocking you know
um no it was I mean it was did you ever
hear of that happening to a gay guy no
no well not as part of our life no now
you know the ironic thing is that you
know back in the ' 70s a lot of guys
were involved with gay bars mhm you know
cuz we wouldn't let them operate unless
they were paying us off you know so I
mean we were involved with gay bars but
you couldn't be in that lifestyle yeah
no could wow did you ever have a friend
who just disappeared one day like and no
one ever you won't be seeing here
anymore like that sort of thing that you
see in the movies like where a guy
you've known for 10 years just gone and
there's no explanation no questions we
were one of the Waring families there
was three wars in the Columbo family
during my lifetime wow that's a lot you
didn't see that in the other families
for some reason I don't know why but um
yeah there were there were many guys
that I knew one day were gone the next
you know one of the most horrible things
um there was a lot of things that you
witness in that life but I had a guy
around me he was actually around my dad
first his big Tony his name was real
tough guy standup Soldier guy he comes
to me one day my dad was away so he was
under me he was one of my guys and he
said to me I'm in a lot of trouble I
said what happened he says I got
involved in a little drug deal and the
boss's son was with me we sold to an
undercover agent and I said I got upset
I said how could you do that you know we
went through that and I said all right
don't worry about it I'll straighten it
out you've been a guy for a long time
you're very well respected he said no
they're GNA blame it all on me he said
the boss's son is GNA skate on this and
they're gonna blame it all on me don't
worry about it this and that and that
right I get on a plane I had a plane at
that time and I head down to
Florida I get to Florida and I get a
call from another one of my guys she
says Mike and I got to believe this I
said what he said Tony went into a phone
booth and blew his brains
out and the reason for that you know one
of the horrors of that life you make a
mistake your best friend walks you into
a room you don't walk out again and he
had said I'm not going to let that
happen to me I'm not going to walk into
that room he was so scared that he had
violated that that he took his own life
went into a phone booth cuz I knew his
wife and and he he called her up and he
said I love you I love the kids and she
didn't understand what he was doing and
boom I mean that's the kind of fear that
that life could put into you and he was
an old-timer so he he understood so that
was a shock to me it was like wow you
know how could you do this you know but
even though he knew that I would go to
bed for him he was even well cuz look
you're told straight out you know your
best friend is going to walk you into
that room so even though I was trying to
assure him he said Mike I know the life
too well you know what I mean yeah so so
much like Good Fellas that in regards to
the the scene where like Henry and um
when Joe pesy walks into the room
remember and he thought he was being
made and boom and uh and that's a
reality of that life but but even even
for example when Hen Henry Hill is
talking to Dao's character and they
having dinner and he's like he's he's
narrating over going yeah I know he's
terrified and he's he's he's plotting
he's telling me everything's going to be
okay it's not going to be okay he's the
one who wants to kill me exact and
that's kind of must have been how your
guy felt but like in terms of you
hearing that news that's the sort of
thing that plays on the mind for days
maybe weeks months afterwards how was
that for you knowing that you had that
conversation with him and even though
you reassured him it didn't matter like
well it it was shocking to the point
where I had my own experience that way
you know Brian when what happened was
there was an article and I I'll relate
it this way I mean that was devastating
to me because I knew him since I was a
kid I used to when I was a kid I called
him Uncle Tony he was that close to me
in my family my father was like one of
his right-hand guys so it was shocking
but um and I'm saying man you know he
didn't trust me and I understood that
but you know know when I was making a
lot of money there was an article that
came out I think it was the Long Island
press that said that I was becoming
powerful enough to break away from the
columbos and start my own family no
truth to it it was like a fictional
story had no truth whatsoever but it
starts to get into people's heads and
like I said we were a Waring family so
my boss started to get a little I got a
big crew I got the Russians involved
with me my dad still had a lot of juice
I'm making tons of money making friends
with other family so you're a threat
yeah so it's like I'm perceived that way
even though I wasn't right so I get a
call one day my dad's on parole Mike I
got to see you so I go see him boss
wants to see us tonight I said okay what
time you want me to pick you up right
because he was uh on parole I used to
drive him well they want you to come in
first they want me to come in second I'm
not going to go through the whole thing
I didn't want to do that because I said
that why they're going to separate us
let's go together you know no no no no
no they we got an order we got to do it
that way long story short I argued with
him a little bit but then gave in I
drive into Brooklyn and to meet with
another guy who I knew my whole life
Jimmy and uh I had to park my car I got
with him cuz the boss was on Parole so
we had to make sure we didn't have a TA
right nobody was following us we get to
this house in Brooklyn where the meeting
was going to take place and I get out of
the car Jimmy walks behind me there was
a guy sitting in the back who I kind of
recognized but didn't know him well and
he walks behind me
and I'm saying this isn't right
something's not right here I don't like
this setup I'll be honest with you br I
got scared I said man they walking me
into this room I said that stupid
article I heard they they went and tried
to talk to some of my guys and right
away I'm thinking I'm in
trouble and uh we go down a steps and it
was probably a 30 yard walk from the car
to the
basement I almost when that door opened
I almost fainted I I said I know the
setup they're going to gu boom I'm going
to get it right in the side of the head
right um but I can tell you it it made a
difference because it was set up that
way to scare me there's no question
about it and that meeting I never I mean
obviously I'm here it worked out okay
but it stayed in my head and I said man
I'm making all of this money and I'm
being put on the spot I'm bringing money
into the family I says I can't trust
anybody here and my father father didn't
do the right thing that night my father
was in there before me and he kind of
threw me under the bus hey if my son is
stealing money I don't know anything
about it he does everything I don't do
anything I'm on parole he took the high
road I found this out and I was like wow
you know and that I didn't say anything
for two years I didn't say you don't in
that life you don't speak at a turn you
don't discuss things with anybody you
keep your mouth shut your feelings
inside but that had a B major impact on
my decision to walk away that must have
broke your heart to a degree it did
break my heart because I said to myself
man if this life can separate Father and
Son cuz my dad and I were tight I said
what do we really have here you know it
was it made a a big impact on me it's I
mean look I always relate things back to
the movies whenever I'm hearing your
stories because that's kind of like a
Fredo moment of like like we were
supposed to be tight and now you're
you're playing both sides like I thought
you know I mean and um and for someone
you've idolized your whole life who you
have so much respect for to do something
not honorable towards you it's heavy
that like it it really hurt it really
hurt and you know when I was I'll never
forget Brian when I I when I talk about
this I it was a summer night in August I
could practically smell the flowers
that's how intense my feelings were
exactly and people said to me why didn't
you cut and run and I I said well it
wasn't heroic it was kind of robotic I
said I was so much a part of that life I
said if this is it this is it I almost
gave in to my death MH how crazy is that
when I think about it you know but you
get so programmed you get so part of it
that it's part of who you are and you
face it that way sort of brainwashed
almost like the Army cuz you kind of are
soldiers a lot of you guys and that's of
the mentality is like you you know
soldiers will run to their death cuz
it's been what they've been told to do
from day one exactly yeah but you know
what Brian it helped me later on because
when I walked away from that life I knew
I was going to have some trouble you
know people weren't going to just let me
go uh but I already knew I said well I
faced death once if I got to face it
again I'll do it for the right reason
it's almost like it helped me later on
cuz I didn't have that fear I mean
ironically what it was supposed to do it
did the opposite it was supposed to give
them control but it actually made you
more Fearless because you were like
well if you're going to take me I'm I'm
not going to I'm not going to go quietly
next time it's going to be a lot
different and I can only assume the am
the sheer volume of cash you were
bringing through the door could have
been one of the main reasons they they
gave you the warning and not the final
shot that night yeah no question about
that and you know I we sat down you know
what happened we were at the meeting and
they're questioning me I started getting
mad I'm saying man I'm bringing all this
money in and now I'm being put on a spot
because of some stupid article that was
written in a paper I said when they
write articles about everybody else it's
false now they writing something about
me it's true I said I don't know this
there's nonsense their real insecurities
were getting triggered it wasn't yeah
yeah so I wonder if you getting angry
helped your case a bit there cuz well
you know you can't get angry with the
boss so I I I caught myself I said wait
a minute I'm walking out of here let me
just you know and then when it was over
you know hey have a glass of wine and
hugging and everything is good you know
no yeah how we ready kill you half now
exactly this is crazy exactly and I got
a little nervous cuz my dad wasn't in
there when I went he had already gone he
went in first and I'm saying where's my
father oh he was here he he's left now
I'm saying to myself did he really leave
am I going to get I mean all these
emotions am I going to get killed here
who's standing behind me all this stuff
is going through my head and I might
have been visibly showing him that I was
nervous tried not to tried to keep my
composure but you know it is what it is
but then like I said it started to turn
to
that you put me on a spot here are you
kidding me you know and then you seem
like an angry guy either so like if
there's one thing that comes off with a
lot of even the videos he did with Sami
and you're very calm composed considered
and I I always think that that's why
you're one of the people who like lasted
the way you did but in that moment for
you to say I I was losing it shows the
intensity of the situation yeah it it
was very I mean look I remember every
little detail about about that night
it's it's amazing it's probably one of
the most standout things in my life the
role of consiliary is something we've uh
seen a lot in these movies and I I
wondered if you could educate us on the
the power of one and how they are
selected the conso are is totally the
selection of the boss you know that's
his advisor so so to speak and his real
role he's supposed to be an intermediary
between the soldiers the men and the
boss cuz if you have a problem with the
boss or something you can't go directly
to the boss you're not allowed to do
that if you're a captain you can but if
you're a soldier you can't so you go to
the consiliary who's the consiliary
allegedly for the family the problem is
if you go to the consiliary with a
complaint about the boss you're probably
not going to last right because he's the
boss's handpick guy so you you don't do
that but you know it's good to have a
consiliary that will disagree with you
and not just yes you to death because
you're supposed to run things by him in
the family it's a powerful position
don't get me wrong but you know I've
noticed in that life you know that the
consiliary and the boss are always it's
almost like one person you know they
they have the same thought pattern the
same everything so you know with me I
just stay in good graces with everybody
that's how I tried to do it I suppose
the the best idea is to pick someone who
will um contain your impulses and try
and help you lead in a more calm way
like rather rather and good thing is the
consiliary normally um deals with the
other families also so you have to have
a guy that's been around that knows how
to deal with people that's that's kind
of well resp obviously well respected so
uh every consiliary that I knew they
were all Old-Timers so when you get
arrested and you are on trial uh in your
position I assume the the guys and the
family are worried that you're going to
say the information to the cops um did
did at any point did you say anything
looking back at it that you regretted to
the cops when they were interrogating
you no well during my arrests you know
and I had so many of them but um I don't
think anybody was ever worried when I
was on trial five
times uh because at that point you know
there was no reason for anybody to worry
about anything you know the controversy
with me afterwards after I walked away
then everybody was worried okay cuz
you're going to cooperate what's uh
what's really going on and the feds
added to that because they put it out
there you know they put my name on a
witness list of trials that were going
on and so people thought I was coming in
to cooperate but I never showed up
because I wasn't doing it that's what
the feds were doing and look I spoke to
the to law enforcement but I didn't give
them any information that could put
people in prison you know I knew what I
could do and what I couldn't do and
mainly I put a lot of stuff on myself
you know so look Brian I was never
willing to go into the Witness
Protection Program I was never willing
to put people in jail that was something
I wouldn't do I would never cross that
line but I needed to show the government
that I was really out because I wanted
them to leave me alone basically I was
so high-profile I arrested 18 times
three racketeering cases two Federal one
state you know leave me alone I had
enough I'm walking away from the life
yeah you want yeah this is what I did
and this and that and that yeah there is
a cause on oer and all of that but that
was my limit and just just so they leave
me alone and then when they put my name
on the witness list everybody was
nervous including my father but I kept
sending my father message Dad I'm not
hurting anybody don't listen to these
people I do 5 years in prison I get out
on parole for 13 months I got a lot of
trouble right both both sides who's
looking to kill me who's looking to put
me in a program it was a mess 13 months
a mess I violate my parole they put me
back in prison so now everybody's saying
why would they put this guy back in
prison if he was going to hurt anybody
the in the discovery they see my name
but then I never show up so that's when
they realized okay he's not hurting
anybody you know so things started to
calm down but this was a long period of
time you know you know look
uh you you got to do what you got to do
if you want to preserve your family I
get it but to me there was a limitation
I wasn't willing to put anybody in jail
I and I told the FED that I said I don't
care what you say I said don't ever
asked me about my father not one word
we'll ever discuss about him about
anything and they they understood that I
said just you know I'm not doing it
period they must have had much on you in
order to put stress on you to try and
pressurize you to give people up or
stuff like that they oh yeah they you
know they're tactic back then we we're
indicting you for murder we're doing it
I mean they hit me with everything I
mean when I was in prison they put me on
diesel therapy Shi me to all different
prisons around the country picked me up
in the middle of the night put you on a
plane you end up someplace you don't
even know where you're going can't visit
they don't tell your family security
reasons then they had me in lockdown for
29 months and 7 Days in solitary you did
29 months solitary 29 months and 7 29
months and 7 days you remember every day
they had me in solitary you know
claiming it was for my own protection
because I walked away from the life but
they were giving me the business and
during that time you want to get out of
here you know just talk to us leave me
alone you know so they're making it as
hard hard as possible they break you
absolutely and you know look there was a
recent video and you know the guy that
prosecuted me said you know Michael
could have put everybody away he was
with Fat Tony and he was with pero and
he the guy said it the prosecutor right
on there but I wasn't willing to do that
so do you think you've got the credit
for that that you probably should have
had though cuz I see the way like when I
was watching the way Samy was talking to
you like it wasn't like that like when I
hear 29 months solitary confinement and
you didn't break
that deserves like respect that like and
I'm not saying you don't get respect but
those people should owe you a level of
gratitude for not doing that well I
think afterwards they did you know you
know what happened there was a when I
was getting out of prison finally my
second stint there was a there was a guy
that was trying to implicate me in a
bunch of murders he was an informant
right turns out they threw him out of
the witness protection program for lying
but the the fedit came to me at the time
and they said listen this guy's imp in
you and all of these deals I said well
he's lying you know and this was before
they found out that he was lying I said
the guy's a liar but they said to me
look you're either going to cooperate
with us because he's implicated other
guys or we're going to indict you for
what this guy is saying I said take your
best shot I told him right and I went
back to my father at the time and I said
Dad I said if I cooperate with this guy
I said everybody's going to get hurt I'm
not going to do it tell them to leave me
Al
alone and he told him that you know he
told my boss and everything leave
Michael my son is not hurting anybody
and that went a long way and then what
happens the guy that said all of this
they threw him out of the program for
lying he was a bad liar he lied about so
many things so you know fortunately that
went and nobody got hurt as a result of
what this guy was saying but there was
so many instances that happened Brian
that I when I think about it you know
how fortunate I am that things just fell
into place for me I mean it was a lot of
work on my part too but I had to you
know be very fortunate that the way
things broke you know honestly you've
navigated things incredibly well in in
one of the most stressful situations but
to to put solitary confinement into the
mix yeah can you describe you know what
that does to the mind for that many
months on end well let me tell you this
I I I am dead set against solitary for
young people MH it's mental torture it's
it's hard it's very very hard I saw a
lot of bad things happen guys that
couldn't handle it after a period of
time and there it was tough for me it
was a faith issue I mean that's when you
know I I really got into my Bible it's
uh it's when I was really in a search
for the truth and what motivated me is
that fedon initially said you're never
get out of here alive you're going to
spend the rest of your life in solitary
so now I'm thinking of Eternity what's
real you know my wife was a Christian my
mother-in-law is a Christian so I doing
my search and I had my wife send me in a
whole bunch of books about different
faiths and that's what that's what
really sustained
me that and my strong determination and
desire to get out and be with my wife
and my children you know my kids and so
I didn't let it get to me it was tough
don't get me wrong I had some very bad
days in there but um you know some
reason I was able to navigate it but
it's it's hard it it really is it's hard
it you know I've always I've always was
kind of assumed because it is a bit
cliche my dad was in prison a lot of my
life and it's kind of like the the thing
that happens is men go to prison and it
seems like from the outside looking in
they start panicking that you know
they're going to meet their makeer
sooner or later and they better start
apologizing for what they've been up to
while they've been here and maybe
they're just trying to get into the
Lord's good graces before they meet him
um but do you think that there was it
felt like there was more to it for you
when you were going through such a
literal dark
and and reading the Bible do you think
that that made you grow as a person yeah
no question no question I started to
look at things differently my mentality
remember mob mentality all the way I
started to see things differently you
know one of the books in the Bible that
was so attractive to me was the Book of
Proverbs because it was such a Wise book
you could you could take God out of the
equation for a minute and just listen to
the wisdom of Solomon brilliant
brilliant and I started to see things
differently and it really did change my
mentality and my heart to a to a degree
and prepared me for what was you know a
new life you know Fish Out of Water I'm
coming out of Brooklyn and the whole mob
thing going into La whole different
atmosphere and now trying to live life
legitimately in the right way and take
care of my family so it was a good
preparation for that um and it really I
started to see things a lot differently
really did it obviously the you know the
is all about essentially what you should
do and how you should live your life did
it make you feel more guilty than you'd
felt previously about the things you'd
done to people um it it it made me
confront myself you know there was one
verse if you notice I have it on my arm
and it says uh it's Proverbs 16:7 when a
man's ways are pleasing to the Lord even
his enemies are at peace with him so
it's one of the first verses that I read
that really got to me because it was the
first night that they threw me in a hole
and they told me you're never getting
out of here this is it you'll never see
your wife and children again and it was
the first time that I was scared I said
I I have no control I'm a controlled guy
by Nature yep no control I lost it they
beat me and when I read that verse I
said man I've got nothing but enemies on
both sides UPS say me the people on the
street I said man I'm going to lose my
wife and kids I'm done and you know I'll
tell you how serious was I used to
demean people that were suicidal I said
you're weak how do you not face up to
you're weak that night I wasn't suicidal
but I kind of understood I wanted to
just lay my head on that c and not wake
up because I said I'm going to do this
to my family I visited my father 25
years my mother practically lost on mind
I said I'm going to torture this woman I
don't know if she going to leave me my
wife I said just take me away I wanted
to lay down and not wake up it was that
serious so when I read that verse it was
almost like man's ways of pleasing to
the Lord I looked back I said who are
you kidding I said you got to confront
what you've done in your life and I
really started to think about everything
what I had done during my time in that
life and I said this is bad and yeah I
had regrets there's no question and so I
didn't you know in in the life you
justify it hey we all took the O right
everyone does this that's why I'm
laughing I've done it justify it but you
know what you could say no also yeah you
know okay you may face consequences but
that's a choice you made I made the
choice to go along with it so yeah I
started to confront my own demons so to
speak during that time it's funny should
say that cuz in the past couple of years
I've definitely tried to be
like I've tried to make those changes of
of the not living the way I used to and
and being that person that I used to not
that I was a really bad guy but I'd make
selfish decisions a lot of the time and
I found it a really painful process in
in looking at everything and trying to
do the right thing cuz sometimes people
don't always want you to do the right
thing you know what I mean and it can be
that you know an emotional situation to
be in for sure oh you know what Brian I
found this you know it's it's a message
that I give to these young Bang Gang
Bangers I tell them listen you are who
you hang out with that's it in life
there's two things you are who you hang
out with and your path in life is going
to be dictated by who you're account
accountable to you know accountability
is everything when I was on the street I
hung out with all criminals I was a
criminal I was accountable to my boss I
was accountable to my oath when I came
out I have to credit my wife with this
because she's an incredibly she's an
honest person she's very very committed
to her faith and the influence that she
had on me number one I didn't want to
disappoint her and number two she
wouldn't stand for me doing anything
wrong so she she helped me change my
mentality to a great degree and then
over a period of time when you're around
somebody that's so consistent it really
helps you and she she was a major force
in my life I was ready for her you know
I had gotten a lot of stuff out of my
system and fortunately I met the right
woman to keep me in the right place yeah
everything you're saying is very
applicable to my own life in the last
few years of like clearing
out people who shouldn't be around you
you know like uh a close person to me
calls it like cutting the Dead Leaves
off the tree to let it grow better and
and like you say the people around you
you know can be a huge difference but
also the woman in your life can make you
or break you without a doubt and this
this that's one thing I've talked to a
lot of cuz I see young YouTube guys
getting a lot of money and I'm like pick
the woman carefully 100% And I'm not
just talking about the ones who give you
a good time and all that like think
about this Lads that's one one of the
things that I think young men they don't
understand the level of importance until
it's too late 100% yeah you know and to
bring that up I don't I don't know what
you're feeling do you know Andrew Tate I
do I do I've had a bit of a running with
him I I
don't I understand that some things he
says are touching a nerve with the young
men of today and I definitely get why
cuz they feel directionless but I hear
the point of young men they need
guidance right now AB I think that
that's uh it's something that they're
crying out for now because there are no
good male role models out there man the
family unit's been destroyed exactly you
know and to me the root of all the
problems that we're having is the
destruction of the family there's no
question you how many guys you might
have experienced the same young men I
met in prison that were in prison you
could write the same script for every
one of them broken home no Father Figure
no Mentor that's it bottom line they're
like little wild animals they gravitate
to the street they get to the local gang
banger drug dealer before you know what
they're in jail and and it's also why
relationships are breaking down
consistently because young women aren't
viewing they're not being raised anymore
young women to view how a man and a
woman are supposed to talk to each other
so for me personally when I started
dating uh you know women I didn't sort
of understand until now why so many
women don't know how to communicate with
men and it's because they've never
watched their mother and father do that
in a functional way they don't say it so
they don't have a clue so they women are
now talking to men men themselves and
they're wondering why it's like a
volatile relationship all the time and
you see these toxic relationships is
because no like the old ways of
communicating and the specific gender
roles in my opinion anyway of a man
being a man and a woman being a woman
ironically worked absolutely and and now
we've gotten so far away from that it's
almost like we've got no chance of
having like thousands of successful
relationships the way it used to be well
it's funny that you say that here in the
UK and it's exactly the same in the
United States and you know I do agree
with Andrew on on a lot of things I mean
men being men the problem is that you
know people view that if man is a man
and acting like he should that it's
demeaning to women and it's not in any
way you know it's actually a benefit to
women and you want a strong woman
nobody's saying we we don't I need a
strong woman my wife is is the best
balance for me in life that I could
imagine because she's strong she's
independent she also knows her role mhm
and I know my role and it's different
but we and the young fit perfectly
exactly exactly and and this is what
young men and young women have to
understand you know be who you are as as
what you are you're a woman I'm a man
and we compliment Each Other Well I
think femininity is the most
underappreciated quality in the modern
era like so many women now are giving up
like the femininity and the way they're
portraying the themselves the way
they're talking the way they're acting
all over their Instagram stuff like that
like the the softer and more gentle you
can be towards a man they'll have them
wrap around their little finger and I'm
like you've literally got the superpower
right there in your hand you don't even
know how to use it because he never been
shown but like if you communicate with a
man is soft gentle feminine way we're
put you in your hands ladies absolutely
it's mental like you aren't even cuz
they think by like stamping their feet
being aggressive being masculine will
get them their way because it's probably
worked in their household when they were
younger it's like but when you try do
that at 25 and upwards with a grown man
that's why your relationship is breaking
down 100% um you know there's a lot of
um backlash now in you you United States
with feminists who finally saying you
know the women that that bought into
this they said we bought into a big lie
absolutely cuz now we're 38 39 40 years
old we were told we never needed a
companion we didn't need men in our life
and now we can't find one well the C AR
very good at cuddling like when they die
um but like um um and another thing is
like for me feminism I understand why
women felt the compelled to want more
power and yes they weren't treated the
way they should have been but it's just
been such an overcorrection now and um
and ironically it's like well well done
you're all taxpayers like the rest of us
like you've given up your role in the
home where and like now a lot of these
women are wanting to buy back in and go
oh actually I want to Pro protect a
provider who earns all the money and I
can just stay with the kids cuz that's
actually what I want to do but they're
40 years old and it's too late exactly
and it's happening all over exactly but
you know my wife a couple of things I
mean I don't let her put gas in the car
I feel that's my job my girl I didn't I
would never I do that I put gas in the
car you know I I do I do everything for
her not that she's not very capable of
doing it on her own and she'll do it on
her own she does respect in it yeah she
doesn't demand me to do it but I hold
her in that high esteem she deserves
that as far as I'm concerned ER hey look
in my case I'm gone 8 years my wife Stu
stood by me you know totally committed
took care of the kids raised them
properly went through hell with me would
you know contract on my life all the
stuff she she had to go through so she's
earned every bit of that and more you
know so but she's capable of doing it on
her own it's not like I'm demeaning her
like but some women would look at that
as oh you know you think I can't do that
on my own well of course you can but if
we're if we want to go out of our way
and do that for you and it makes us feel
good and it treats you a certain way why
are you mad about that some some some
some women I see interviews and look
they go viral because they're they're
ridiculous sometimes so they they're
meant to be triggering but I see someone
who want it kind of both ways they want
the independence but they also want the
guy who's going to do like everything
and I don't know I I'm really glad that
I am got to pick a wife out of the
future Generations God bless these young
men out here if they watching um but
yeah I I completely see where you're
coming from M so we were talking about
the time you were in jail and obviously
you mentioned your father's time in jail
and he being framed how common do you
think it was for people in your business
to be framed by the police back in the
day normally an investigation starts a
crime is committed and then law
enforcement investigates the crime right
well with us guys they don't know what
the crime is they're investigating the
guys waiting to see what crime has
committed you know so um it's like
reverse engineering it they must have
done something they must have done let's
figure out what it is so they surveil us
they watch us they talk to people they
try to find out he's got to be involved
in something we think we know what it is
and so it gives them leeway to you know
what I mean to exaggerate to a point
where it's fra and my dad's out andout
frame very simple these bank robbers
really robbed all the banks they just
created one meeting and said my dad was
at that meeting and ordered them to do
it that was it wow one meeting he
ordered them to do it but the banks at
robberies actually took place and and
what happened is the FBI put the my
dad's name in their thinking they knew
my father they knew of my father because
of of his reputation and so it was easy
to set it up and the jury bought it you
know the jury bought it but the thing is
in the federal system you don't need any
corroboration you can be you can go to
jail on the basis of one person you know
telling a story about you if the jury
buys it they buy it normally they'll
want to present a little bit more than
that you know but uh it's a tough system
and you you've been put on the spot
quite a few times about oh have you
killed people d d and I seen Samy sort
of you know putting it on you a bit
about well what did you do and you were
like I can't say um but I've got a
hypothetical question that sort of
brooches it cuz I was thinking about
this um knowing that you can't say
anything like to that level but let's
just say hypothetically if you had have
taken another man's life in the in in
the life you were
in the character you have and the person
you are now someone who is religious and
really believes and doing the right
thing it seems let's just say that
you're on your deathbed one day do you
think that if you had have done that
that you are the type of person who
would say that on your deathbed or do
you think that you would never speak of
it well let's put it this way I uh I
made you know I'm Christian and I made
my peace with God and fortunately as a
Christian you don't have to make your
peace with anybody
else um but you know I'm I'm going to
say I had a sit down with Jordan
Peterson okay great man brilliant guy
I've had him on the show and he said to
me my I said look Jordan you know there
was certain things I did in that life
that I was very uncomfortable with uh I
did them anyway and he said well how'd
you do that and I said well quite
honestly I kind of stepped outside of my
myself and did what I had to do and then
came back into
myself and and I think that's how I
approached it hey I've got an order this
has got to be done boom but then Jordan
said to me
well is the real person the person that
steps out of itself or the person that
steep back and I said whoa I said I'd
like to think it was the person that I
stepped back into because I don't have
those same thoughts now look am I
capable of doing I'm a made member of
that life of course you're
capable um but I'm
not I'm not at Liberty to talk about
anything I you know to me to me it's
offensive to to people to talk about
there's other guys that brag about it I
don't understand how they do that you
know and my father taught me something
once he said to me this and and it stuck
with me and it it might be one of the
reasons why I didn't have certain
trouble in my life he said to me Mike if
you and I were out and we rob robbed a
store 15 seconds after we robbed that
store if you say to me dad that was a
good deal we did I he would say to me
what are you talking about he said why
would you ever bring it up again why
would you put yourself in trouble or
expose yourself he said you never ever
have to talk about something that you
did done finished when it's illegal
activity so I that's always been in my
head you know I also said something to
Jordan This is interesting he said
Michael how do you feel about lying and
I said well my dad again put something
in my head I would never lie to hurt
somebody I might lie to help somebody
and he looked at me he said well lying
is lying I said I know but I'm lying to
help somebody you know for instance you
know my son you know got himself in
trouble the cops came to me did your son
do this I'd say no I want to help my son
he's my blood he's this and that and he
had an issue with that and it started to
make me think you know Michael you can't
justify lying lying is lying is lying
but I don't agree with that I'm going to
be honest with you if I had to help
somebody somebody in my family I I may
lie to help them there also White Lies
which are seem to be less hurtful to
people yeah yeah but to lie to hurt
somebody and lie to put somebody in
trouble no that to me is very offensive
and it's it's cowardly I wouldn't do
that and keeping your mouth shut even to
regular people say for example if I'm
talking to a young YouTuber and they're
starting to get a lot of money my advice
would be keep your mouth shut because
people are envious and envious people
found envious people will stab you in
the back the first chance they get and
that's on on everyday level like and you
you know this is the world of YouTube
crisis um so um apologies I shouldn't
say that in front of a religious man
like yourself that's okay I get it no
but um but you know what psychologically
you're talking about what Jordan
Peterson said and he has an interesting
question because you've lived a life
with people around you who were who were
able to kill and kill many
people the average person the average
people
how able to do that do you think most
people would be if they were in the
situation where no one finds out and
you're put on the spot you got to do
this or else this like where do you rank
average people in that sense I think it
would be hard for some but I think most
could do it you know I I'm going to say
something that's kind of controversial
and and and I hope people don't get me
wrong you know but you take a young man
18 years old you put him in the military
he's trained to fight and kill mhm you
know and the way I look at it is murder
is murder if you have the ability if
it's in you to kill somebody it's still
murder it might be justified don't get
me wrong because you're fighting for
your country you're defending people I
get it and I'm not comparing that to
murder in the mob because they're the
different reasons but you're still
capable of doing that you know what I
mean you're committing a murder whatever
the circumstances are so I guess an
answer to your question I think I think
a lot of people are capable of doing
that if they were put in a situation and
yeah like this is I got to do this and
nobody's going to know about it cuz some
of the things you hear I don't know how
it is here but I read things in the
papers every day I cannot believe some
of the things that are happening I mean
women killing their husband killing
their kids and it's like it has to be a
mental illness issue with them but uh
it's more prevalent than we think you
know we look at murder as the ultimate
sin and probably it is but it happens
quite a bit I mean yeah and it's
obviously generations of of of people
Savages building up into society that we
have now like this is it was very common
like you know when when especially back
when the laws were nowhere near strict
and the ability to stop people from
killing people was nowhere near and
speaking for myself like I think I'm a
good guy I would never want to murder
anyone but in the circumstances if it's
me or versus another guy then like you
got to do what you got to do I suppose
if you had to defend yourself or defend
your family no choice is that really no
you're going to do it I think I think
most people can do it in that situation
you know so it's in you as a human being
again it's it's it's look you separate
that from people that are just insanely
murderous you know we we've known them
um it feels like when you're describing
some of those guys earlier that almost
you know the mafia was the vehicle for
them to um enjoy that thrill like you
said they were just serial killers who
happen to be in the mafia but if they
weren't there they would have been out
like lunatics exactly yeah exactly
that's that's the truth so you mentioned
earlier about leaving the mafia can you
describe how that felt when you finally
felt free and you know how that came
about how because to Mastermind that
must have been really difficult you know
it was difficult I would for for a long
time I struggled I would go to bed
leaving the life wake up no I can't do
this and for me it was it
was probably even more difficult because
the relationship I had with my dad and
not wanting to betray him in his mind
you
know so it was really a a struggle an
emotional you know struggle with me and
when I walked away you know I'll tell
you a story I got violated just before I
got violated my dad called me he was on
Parole and I was out in California I was
on Parole and he said we need you back
here the family's going to war we were
have another war in our family overpower
right
struggle and he said stop your nonsense
walking away we need
you and I was so torn Brian so torn I
said man how could I turn my back on
guys they need me and blah blah blah and
I'm back and I would again I was trying
to figure out a way how to break my
parole not really tell my wife and go
back to New York and see what I can do
to try to help in some way decide that I
would be on and I had made the decision
to go back I said no I got to do this I
was feeling just terrible well what
happens just after I make the decision
I'm walking out of a bank and there's 15
agents they violate my parle and I'm
going into solitary for 29 months and 7
days I was in solitary the entire time
the war went on oh wow I get released in
the war is over so was that a blessing
in disguise absolutely absolutely a
blessing in dis guy I probably wouldn't
be here right now had I engaged in that
so you know fortunately and again to me
it's a faith issue you know God had a
different plan for me for sure because I
had made the wrong decision I had made
the wrong decision dumb decision and I
would have destroyed my life and my
family and everything else obviously the
the mafia still exists to some degree um
how do you think those guys look at you
now well since there's a whole new
generation of guys everybody in my life
that I knew dead or in prison they're
all gone and I think uh I don't think
they have a real resentment towards me I
honestly don't and I know that because
of you know I'll share this with you
there was one guy that was my Capo Jim
he was my captain and I was very very
close with him and he did some time in
prison he got out and he was the boss of
the family for a while and when I was
visiting my father uh my father said
let's go see him he wants to see you so
this was an oldtime guy this was after
everything and but we had gotten along
really well so I think the attitude on
the street was he didn't hurt anybody
you know it's okay I honestly and I
don't want to come off the wrong way I
think a lot of guys saying man because
they see I have a life for myself I got
a wife I got kids I got grandkids we're
on YouTube we're doing things I got I
think a lot of guys say you know what I
I wish I could reach that level or have
that peace in my my life and have that
you know I think there are guys cuz look
it's a tough life to navigate man and I
believe a lot of guys in are in it if
they could have lived their life
differently they would did you have like
any vices that you turned to you know
cuz you said you weren't really a drug
guy but you know like when a man's
stressed in pressure men do things do
did you have a vice that you would use
to take that pressure off honestly no I
mean it's unbelievable I never drank
really now I love wine I mean yeah I
drink drink wine obviously my wife and I
we go to Napa Valley we enjoy that and
again I I attribute a lot of that to my
dad my dad was very disciplined in his
behavior he didn't smoke he didn't drink
you know he didn't do drugs ever he
hated drugs you know so and I really
wanted to please him and emulate him and
so I mean I that's why you know people
oh your dad was this I said hey when I
was growing up he was a good father he
taught me the right way he taught me to
respect women he taught me to have
integrity you know so a lot of people oh
but your dad was a killer he was this he
was that my issue with my dad was this
and I I I'll bring it out you know I
after my mom passed away I sat down with
him and what got me is that he didn't
take responsibility for the destruction
of his
family and he would say to me he would
actually blame my mother blame this and
I and I said Dad you need to take
responsibility he said nope not my fault
I got framed if I didn't get framed none
of this would happen I said dad you
didn't get framed because you were a
doctor a lawyer or a priest you got
frame because we're mobsters and that's
what they do we understand that he could
never accept it accountability is huge
isn't it in in forgiveness like it's
very hard to forgive someone unless
they're coming to you with good faith
yeah now he might have accepted that
internally but he couldn't say it out
loud and it it I had
I had an issue with that with him cuz he
blamed my mom for a lot of things you
know and I said come on you know and and
initially some I would blame my mom I
always took my father's side always
until she got sick and was passing away
and I spent a lot of time with her and
she said things to me that never I guess
because now I'm married and I love this
woman and I looked at what my mother
said from a different perspective and my
wife understood my mother a lot better
than I did she said what do you expect
from this woman look what she went
through and I never looked at it that
way we looked at things differently yeah
so she opened my eyes and I was more
open to what my mother had to say and
you know I don't know you know it's it's
amazing I don't care what age you are
you can always you can always learn
more mate when when we're younger I feel
like we judge our parents so harshly
until it's time for us to be that age
and to and to live that life and all of
a sudden you see it through those
different eyes and you realize I
forgive you for a lot of this now um and
I understand how just how hard it is my
mom died when I was younger and I almost
feel like now as I'm older I'm getting
to know her still and understanding her
on a totally different level almost as
like her equal now I'm like oh so this
is why oh okay I get it and um it is a
phenomenal thing that we have to go
through and I was just sort of wondering
if when you go to sleep at night do you
have a dream about the old days is that
sort of replaying sometimes or are you
completely clear of it right I got to
tell you this my wife shocked me the
other day because I fight a lot in my
sleep oh I don't know this but the other
day she was so moved by it she took a
video of me and I was actually really
fighting I was angry I was
this again I maybe the demons come out
during that time I don't ever remember
anything really but it happens a lot and
she said I said come on it can't be like
that but she showed it to me and I was
like it was scary for a minute it was
like uh something possessed meh I'm I'm
not kidding and I said wow I don't know
maybe that's when it comes out yeah I
guess maybe that's kind of like going
back to the Jordan Peterson thing of
like you know is it really the other
side of you or is it just Tu away
somewhere and maybe when your
unconscious you know is allowed to come
out at night maybe it's rearing its head
a little bit yes yes yeah we're going to
have to get your wife a baseball bat or
something just in case
I know sometimes she'll shove me I said
what are you doing she do you realize
what you're doing I said of course not
I'm sleeping I've got I like the end the
interview with a few sort of general
questions just to see what they bring
out of each guest cuz I think that it's
sort of interesting so of all the time
you you know you spent on this planet
what's the hardest thing you feel like
you've been through believe it or not
one of the toughest things and one of
the things I'm I'm very angry about
what's going on in my country my
youngest daughter I have five daughters
two boys my youngest daughter
was very much in love with a young man
24 years old and they were going to get
engaged and he was actually my
videographer you know he was doing all
my video work very talented in that
regard and uh an athlete 6'2 good-look
guy wonderful disposition just a
wonderful young man well I'm speaking in
Chicago he was initially from Michigan
so he was living in my house in in uh
California we had a guest
room and I'm on my way to the airport
and I have ring on my phone where I
don't know if you have that here the
video comes up and it's 6:00 in the
morning back in LA and ring comes on the
door of my house is open and police are
walking in and out of my house I'm like
what the heck you know what's going on
all these things went through my head
then I see the
paramedics so now my wife and daughter
are home what happened I'm going crazy
I'm trying to call nobody's answering
make a very long story short this young
man took an Aderall Aderall that these
kids do they try to stay up to do their
test in college right that was laced
with fent andol within 10 minutes
collapsed on my bathroom floor and died
Oh my he was poisoned wasn't an addict
he was poisoned
right so my daughter was so
traumatized uh Brian that for six months
we couldn't go back in the house I
thought I was going to have to move it
took her it's only the last three months
this happened a little over two years
ago that she's come out of it but to see
what this young girl went through my
daughter that I love you know she's my
only child out of seven that I was with
since birth No Interruption with prison
so we're very tight and my wife found
him too so the two of these women the
two women in my life were traumatized to
watch her go through this was probably
the most difficult thing out of
everything that I've experienced and
we're talking a lot that that I had to
go through and that we had to go through
as a family and it's it's got me so
angry because I know what Going H coming
down on our Southern border all the
drugs that are coming through a 100,000
people a year dying being half of them
being poison Reon not even addicts with
this stuff that's coming through so I I
think that's the most and I'm I'm be
honest with you I'm so angry about it
right now that I have to pray to sub my
make my anger subside because you don't
want your anger to get the best of you
you make wrong decisions but it's
something that's uh even harder than
being in a
hole I hear that like I really feel like
that pain and uh I think it says a lot
about you that my question of what's the
hardest thing you've been through was
watching someone else's pain yeah and
not your own so you know I respect that
you have a lot of empathy for your
daughter and uh you know I hope that you
can get through um what is going to be
probably you know a few more years of
dealing with this to come to terms with
it cuz a death like that it it it is a
sudden deaths are I've I've known them
and they're very hard to to deal with
you know especially your daughter being
so young so much for her to go through
and uh yeah I mean
that is so difficult it's tough and
fortunately for the last three months
she starting to this was the in other
words she's been okay for a week and
then boom goes back into depression but
these last three months she's been like
for two years we couldn't celebrate
Christmas we didn't have a Christmas
because it was just too hard for her we
understood to watch your someone you
love go through that pain it's oh gosh
it was it was torture and and and they
say it is true like time is that healer
that that people like need and um you
just you just uh I'm assuming that
you're getting a counseling and that
sort of stuff to try and help her
through it therapy our church was
terrific and I got to tell you this
Brian do you love animals I certainly do
man yeah she we have this uh Siberian
Husky I fell in love with this dog like
you have she's a wonderful dog but what
she's done for my daughter oh my gosh
it's like she's been a breath fresh air
in the house and my my daughter actually
travels with us she's not with us now
because she didn't want to leave the dog
because we're coming back for the tour
and we have other things planned so she
didn't want to spend that much time away
from our little NOA so I always enjoyed
animals and loved animals but now it's
like this is like a child in our house
she's been so well appreciated I was
just saying this recently in the last
week to someone like they animals but
dogs especially they're like they're
like batteries they literally charge
everyone up with
unbeliev what they do what's your
biggest regret up now I have a few but
you know I have a couple um I was
married early on before I met my wife
for a short period of time I had three
children with her good woman nothing
negative to say but one of my biggest
regrets was not being as close with
mainly my two daughters I had two
daughters and a son my son is out with
me he's been with me for 15 years uh but
my two girls I never was able to
solidify that relationship number one
because I divorced their mom and we were
separated and with my I didn't only
leave them I left them because I went
right to jail so I was like really gone
out of their lives and was never able to
repair it to the point that I should M
and I take the blame for that it's my
responsibility as a father maybe I
didn't do everything I should have done
I don't know but that's a deep regret um
and the other regret is you know not as
a person of Faith we're supposed to
share our faith with the people that we
love I didn't do that to the right
extent with my dad I feel that I could
have done more and it was just very hard
for me to communicate with him on that
basis that's not an excuse I should have
still worked it harder but I didn't and
that's a regret because you know as a
Christian we believe in heaven and hell
and you know hopefully my dad is where
he's in heaven and he made his uh his uh
you know his peace with the Lord but if
that didn't happen am I somewhat
responsible because I didn't do enough
you know so it's something that's going
to stay with me until I find out you
know put it that way who was it that
inspired you the most in your life well
early on it was my dad I have to say
that and it's been my wife I mean she
yeah absolutely my wife she she's not
only has she inspired me she's kept me
on the right track I'm not perfect don't
get me wrong I mean I she she has she
has a work cutout for with me let me
tell you I'm not the easiest guy to keep
on track all the time and I've made
mistakes in my life you know look
marriage is difficult when everything is
great but when you have the pressure
that we had eight years in prison all
this kind of stuff the mob
mentality um it's even more difficult
but you know we were totally committed
to one another and here we are 38 years
later through all of these conditions
but she has uh inspired me to be a
better
person and to to do the right things and
she's kept me on track for the most part
years what's your tip uh if if you had
to give one in terms of as a man you
know uh being a good husband well you
know they say happy happy wife happy
life you know again it's look no matter
what nonsense maybe my wife knows that I
love her very much I in many ways put
her on a pedestal because she's earned
that she deserves that and I enjoy
treating her that way you know and in
turn she gives me everything that I need
you know she's very compliant in that so
maybe that's the wrong word I don't want
to you know she's yeah yeah yeah I got
to CH you may fold on a questioning
exactly she uh you know she does the
right thing with you know so we
compliment each other
well um yeah man and we're opposite in a
lot of ways okay she's I got to say this
she's a better judge of character than I
am yeah you know and with my wife you
don't have too many She'll always love
you she'll pray for you but if she
thinks you're not the right person
you're going to have to work very very
hard to get back into her Graces cuz
she's very intuitive that way I tend to
be easy you know and she'll tell me
you're making a mistake then no I don't
don't worry about him and she's writing
should have made a better mob boss than
you she might she might have but uh and
she's very protective of me also you
know she watches uh this and I
appreciate that well yeah I mean cuz now
you're a man of value you're you're
you're literally able to help all these
people which means people want to be
helped so I'm assuming she's got her
eyes peeled and uh that's a healthy
thing because kind of like what we were
saying about the consiliary role that
you were saying earlier is you don't
want to consiliary who's a yes man who's
just going to be the same as you and a
relationship is a lot like having you're
both consiliary for each other I guess
like that sort of absolutely and fitting
in where each other or weaker makes for
a better scenario in my opinion than two
people are identical um and in terms of
your life who do you feel was the one
that let you down the most um I think it
was my dad you know in the end and I I
don't want it like it's I'm not
complaining about it but it was
disappointing to me the way in both of
those areas number one you know what
happened that night I felt it was a
betrayal MH and number two not taking
responsibility and another thing you
know after my dad was
um was violated for the third time you
know and the family's falling apart
excuse me I said to him dad our family
is falling apart you need to get out of
New York let's go to Florida California
whatever and put the family back
together forget everything else
prioritize the family yes he wouldn't do
that and as a result the family's
destroyed and I initially I didn't hold
that against him but later on I said he
could have made a he could have walked
away my dad earned it hey you know what
I got to worry about my family I'm on
parole I can't associate with anybody
and nobody would have held it against
him exactly because of who he was his
position yeah but he chose to his his
bigger Allegiance was to that life the
problem my dad had his legacy meant
everything in the life not as a husband
and a father reputation over reality
exactly and when I realized that that
was wrong it was very disappointing yeah
and I he he should have been a different
man in that
regard yeah and I always relate things
that people tell me to my own life and
that is that reputation of a reality
thing is definitely something I've been
aware of lately like cuz when everyone
starts knowing who you are whatever the
reason is it can go to your head and it
can become the number one focus and it
it's such a mistake it's an easy trap to
fall into that many men especially cuz
we have egos right we want everyone to
know how great we are course how why
else would I be sitting in front of the
camera um but you know I have to uh
being a better man is always the most
important thing to me now and I'm glad
I've sort of in my 30s managed to figure
that out uh because I've seeing some men
as you've described there kind of it's
too late yeah to put it right and that's
such an important thing and I know young
men watch this show and if they are
listening like if you aren't happy with
your who the real person is definitely
is you've got to figure that out quicker
than what people think of you for sure
yeah and you know Brian I have uh I
visited prisons quite a bit and you know
kind of ministered to men in there and
this is what I tell young man I can't
tell you how many guys 50s you know late
40s 50s early 60s and they turn around
they'll say to me Michael look at my
life mhm you you know what did I do I
wasted all these years all this time I
don't have a wife now I don't know what
I'm going to do I'm spending my time in
prison you know and and they don't
realize what they're doing to themselves
you know until reality really hits and
it hits hard and that's why I tell these
young men listen you're only young once
do the right thing and young so that
when you get old you're set up properly
you're older years and um you know a lot
of a lot of young guys may oh I have
time I have time no you don't have time
do it now get yourself in shape now in
the right way um do you know you one
that hit me when I turned 35 because my
whole life I thought by 35 I'll have it
all figured out and I turn 35 I thought
I need to make some big changes here the
clock is ticking exactly yeah um but see
there again you know that's when you
need guidance you need mentorship you
need people telling you things you know
one of one of the things that I
attribute to some of the success I had
is I was always a good listener I paid
attention to people and even now if
somebody like I'll sit there and wow if
somebody has something smart to tell me
I want to pay attention I don't know
everything you know I can learn and uh
and and being a good listener when
people told me to do things that were
smart I tried to pay attention to that
and it pays off in the end there's no
question well my last question mate um
and this has been fantastic by the way
one last question how would you like to
be
remembered my legacy
um a good husband a good father to my
children grandfather to my uh to my uh
grandchild and just that you know he did
benefit the community and the people
around him and basically that's what you
want to be if you can be known as that
or known for that you've you've lived
your life okay well that was amazing
I've thoroughly enjoyed this one one of
my favorites uh this was Michael Frances
on the true Jordie podcast you can catch
it to uh he's coming of the UK you can
watch his YouTube channel you can buy
the books I'll put all the links in the
description below thank you very much
Michael really appreciate well thank you
Brian and I have to say this this was
you you got things out of me that I
haven't spoken about before and I really
appreciate that and I have a lot more to
talk about on the tour but I just want
to thank all the people of the United
Kingdom I I mean I've been more accepted
here than anywhere in the world and
people are always nice and gracious but
to a greater extent here MH uh and I
really appreciate that and you guys have
won me over so amazing amazing we'll
keep coming back um don't forget you can
check out the two out links in the
description below if you haven't already
hit that like button subscribe to the
true Jordy YouTube channel thanks for
watching we'll see you on the next one
thank you very much Michael Brian that
was great loved it I really mean it good
job you know thank you very
[Music]
much
oh